I want to eat pulp if you don't mind
just tell me about it we had for
breakfast this morning as a soundcheck
soundcheck breakfast coffee this
altitude I can run flat out for a half
mile before my hands start shaking when
I also personal question now it is soon
I must - Eric organism living tissue
over metal endoskeleton so thank you for
supporting the sponsors this show
99designs which is your one-stop shop
for all things graphic design related go
to 99designs comm forward slash tim to
see the projects that I've put up
including the mock-ups and drafts of the
book cover for the 4-hour body as always
you can subscribe to this podcast on
iTunes and you can find all of the links
and resources from this episode as well
as every other episode by going to four
hour work week comm forward slash
podcast spell it all out or you can go
to four hour work week calm and just
click on podcast feedback if you have
feedback I would love your thoughts
anything at all who you'd like to see on
this show ping me on twitter at ste
Ferris that's Twitter comm /tf ER Riss
or on facebook at facebook.com forward
slash Tim Ferriss with two R's and two
S's hello ladies and gentlemen this is
Tim Ferriss and welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where of
course I try to deconstruct world-class
performers whether they be billionaire
investors chess prodigies athletes and
everything in between to pull apart
tease out the tactics and tools and
resources that you can use and this
episode was a real treat I had so much
fun with this it was easily one of the
most enlightening and lucid
conversations about physical training
I've ever had and we covered everything
meaning strength flexibility endurance
and beyond and my guest is none other
than Pavel Tatsu Lyn and yes that is how
you say it he is chairman of strong
first Inc and was born in minks not in
Pink's Minsk I always have so much
trouble saying that not that I say it
that much USSR former USSR which is now
part of Belarus in 1980s he was a
physical training instructor for spent
in US that's also another one I want to
miss pronounce always it's not Spetsnaz
spent NAS the elite Soviet Special
Forces units
Pawel is now subject matter expert to
the US Marine Corps u.s. Secret Service
and the u.s. Navy SEALs and he is also
perhaps you know this or not he is
widely credited with introducing the
kettle bell to the United States the
ubiquitous kettle bell which is called
kettle ball by almost everyone maybe
that should be changed make things
easier
in any case over the last several years
Pawel has become a friend of mine I'm
honored to call him a friend and his
input was critical to the success and
many of the experiments of the 4-hour
body whether you have heard of him or
not stick with this interview prepared
to have your mind blown and I really
don't say that lightly you're going to
enjoy this and you will have a lot to
take notes on and there will of course
be tons in the show notes at 4-hour
workweek comm forward slash podcast but
without further ado here we go please
meet Pavel tattooin Pavel welcome to the
show Begich it I'm so thrilled to have
you and I thought we would start with
the the answer to a question that I ask
all of my guests which is how do you
pronounce your name properly above all
said Sulu
SOT suelen and that's right and you'd
mentioned before we came on what you
tell people at Starbucks if you order
coffee and what is that it just has to
be Pablo coffee for Pablo there's no
other way and I really admired your work
and expertise and also just your method
of teaching quite frankly for so many
years and I was having trouble piecing
together how we first came in contact of
course I was well aware of your work
prior to us having us having any direct
contact but how do you recall how we how
we came to know each other yes I did Tim
as you I'm a big fan of simplicity in my
life and different aspects of my life
and 4-hour workweek really resonated
with me and at that point I remember
writing an article and I entitled that
article Ferris Bueller's Day at the gym
yes and I said you that article is
submitted for blah that's right that's
right okay and that that really set a
cascade of events in motion and I became
very very fascinated I mean of course
like a lot of people I think I was
initially exposed to you as the strength
trainer who used the word comrade a lot
and really hadn't hadn't delved into a
lot of the details of your strength
training specifically which will of
course get into and I guess there are
two questions I'd love to ask but the
first is what do people consider you the
people who know you well what do they
consider you world class at Tim I have
been able to take very complex subjects
take them apart and put them back
together in a matter that's very simple
that can be delivered to regular people
without losing the essence of what these
of the systems so I'm talking about
specifically serious strength training
I'm talking about both programming and
I'm talking about what I would refer to
as the body language of strength and can
you explain for people who are perhaps
not not inductees into the world of
strength training yet what do you mean
by programming programming planning your
training you go from A to B you want to
add 50 pounds to deadlift this is what
you do and unfortunately the world of
programming is very confused well the
whole world of fitness is very confused
and again what I attempt to do is to
bring principle-based training so when
you understand the principles
applications or many applications are
easy right and I think that's where I
feel such a such a degree of kinship
with what you try to do with these
subjects because of course whether I
succeed or fail and sometimes I do both
that's very much what I try to do with
the subjects that I tend to obsess on
and for those who are familiar with your
background you've worked with many
different types of
athletes and also Special Forces and so
on would you mind just giving a little
bit of background on your your bonafide
so to speak some of your your your
background as it relates to to training
certain I used to be a PT training
instructor physical training instructor
for Spetsnaz the Soviet Special Forces
and my education is in sport science and
I did over the years trained a number of
high-end units in the West I've been a
subject matter to us Marine Corps to the
US Secret Service to US Navy SEALs and
others and my methods are used
officially by some very high-end
military and counter-terrorist units in
two countries that are main allies of
the United States what I do
pardon me I'm sorry no it's just mymy
brain errupted with something
nonsensical please continue so so what I
do is I take methods that perform very
well in very rugged environments and I
take this methods and I apply it to
other environments so if somebody
decides I just want to change my life I
want to get stronger I want to have a
better game of tennis I want to succeed
in a given sport I take these same
methods that have been tested by
operators at war and I bring these
people the same methods in debt just to
to to drill into that because I've seen
the many I'm sure at this point
thousands of photographs that are sent
to you by deployed troops overseas or
people in Special Forces of their
kettlebells or or they're they're
they're they're rigged the rigged gyms
with you know a sort of makeshift
pull-up bars and whatnot what what is it
that you have to keep in mind when
you're designing or why have why of your
methods had such appeal for elite
military what what are the things that
you've considered perhaps that other
people have not for those types of
trainees Walton Plutarch who said
thousands of years ago that they trained
of a soldier and the training of an
athlete is radically different that an
athlete has the luxury of pampered
lifestyle and the soldier doesn't so
this is pretty much the difference so
what you want to do is you want to build
the training that becomes in the words
of one of my favorite authors Nassim
Taleb anti fragile is the type of
training training that thrives on very
harsh environment that's really robust
in these different environments and
that's pretty much the difference how do
we do that we have to strip all the
non-essentials down pretty much what you
do in your work with different business
with lifestyle and so on and once we get
down to the things that really matter
and we apply them then everything
suddenly becomes very simple have you
spent any time with nothing no I have
not oh I am I'm looking forward to oh I
should I should introduce you guys at
some point he's he's exactly what you
see is what you get if you've read his
books and I think you guys would really
hit it off the the you know the what you
just said brought to mind a a
conversation that I had with a friend of
mine who was formerly Navy SEAL and now
he's doing things that he can't tell me
about not that he could tell me much
about what he did before but he and
actually not to be named but and now
that now that I think of it you
introduced us I was going Victoire
Victor
yes Victor amazing guy and Victor is is
the most efficient trash compactor I've
ever seen in my life he he can eat
anything and make fuel out of it and he
was he was criticizing in a very
good-natured way some of his colleagues
because he said well you know you know
some of the guys that diet that I work
with out in the field you know some of
them are the bodybuilder types and they
get really grumpy if they can't have
their protein shake every two or three
hours he's said I view it as a real
competitive and practical advantage that
I can I can consume anything and then go
for a 30 40 50 mile run well in Victor
40 strength also that gentleman is
exceptional both in his strength in his
indoor
but for his strengths he relies on the
nervous system not so much in the muscle
tip and again that's what so this is
what's so different you can if you look
at a typical person and how do we get it
stronger let's say that you have a
four-cylinder engine and what the person
would do is they would make that you
know six-cylinder engine but before
you're firing in to now you're firing in
three but if instead what you do is you
learn to fire in all four so there are
ways of training a nervous system to
engage your capacity so much more fully
and if you look at high level performers
at night body weight in some fields
let's say a very high level martial
artist somebody very skinny breaking a
stack of boards or very skinny guy like
Lamar can't deadlifting five times his
body weight so this is so much about the
concentration of mental force and for
your listeners I could give a very
simple example how you can use you can
do that on your gym let's say that you
perform try to the simplest exercise
possible try to the dumbbell curl or
barbell curl because I know you're
sissies out there you'll do that and so
let's say that you're going through your
curls and things are suddenly started to
get tougher so when they suddenly start
to get tougher I want you to just crush
the dumbbell or the barbell or the
kettlebell whatever it is that you're
curling just white knuckle white knuckle
pressure and what you will see is you're
going to definitely going to be able to
get several more repetitions out I'm
going to give you two more techniques in
addition once you have practiced that
then on the next set in addition to
crushing the bar and the way up also
contract your glutes as tight as
possible like somebody's going to kick
you in the butt very very tense you're
just like crunchy will not and at the
same time tighten your abs as if
somebody's going to kick you which you
know somebody might so if you do that if
you do these three things if you
contract your glutes contract your abs
contract your grip everything that
should do absolutely everything is going
to be greatly amplified
and this is just a small example of the
skills of strength that I do teach and
and we're gonna we're gonna dig really
deeply into this because I I have
personally reached a point where I want
to return to the training of a an
athlete who's trying to optimize
relative strength as opposed to just
packing on slabs and pounds of muscle
which quite frankly just my frame and my
joints and my entire system is is
finding aggravating to sustain just the
the full time eating and other vult die
immediate and that's what gets me oh god
it's the worst ah especially as someone
who has depending on how you look at it
like the most acute form of conditioned
like body dysmorphia or orthorexia
possible through buta decade of
wrestling it's my eating habits are
really astonishing sort of like a German
Shepherd is like broken into the pantry
and eating sticks of butter on more than
more than a few occasions but the the
question I wanted to ask you uh next is
what are the biggest misconceptions that
people have about Pavel tot suelen and I
am training myself to say taht suelen
because I've heard everyone say Tatsu
lean so I'm trying to correct that but
what are the biggest misconceptions that
people have about you well Tim they call
me the kettlebell guy I think only the
father of the kettlebell which I
appreciate very much I did introduce
together my business partner I did
introduce the kettlebell to the West and
right now the kettlebell has become a
mainstream but what I'm really all about
it's above the principles the
underlining principles of strength
training the underlying principles of
power generation and it doesn't really
matter what modality you use whether you
use a kettlebell the barbell your body
weight whether your arm rest and
fighting lifting rocks it really doesn't
matter so I am NOT about the kettlebell
I am about the principles that make it
strong what I have done is I have
reverse engineered the way the strongest
people move naturally and I have brought
it to the people I've shown to people
how to move in this manner and how to
shave off years and if not decades after
trying to progress to much higher level
you've worked with some incredible
strength athletes would you mind
mentioning some of them and some of them
we've caught co-authored books with but
who were some of the strength athletes
that you've collab or strength trainers
that you've collaborated with Andy
Bolton Andy Bolton he is the first
person to deadlift or thousand pounds he
is a he's an amazing athlete he's a very
very smart trainer
so Andy bolt and I we have written a
book together called the deadly dynamite
and the reason Andy and I have written
this project together is again and he's
very smart trainer and his particular
style of deadlift looks exactly like the
kettlebell swing that I teach so it's
again that fit of the body language I
have written a book called easy strength
with Dan John Dan John is a strange
coach extraordinaire you would really
love interview and Dan on the show
because he's a beast Dan is and who's so
again he just gets past the fluff he
gets to the things that matter and Dan
does not try to impress you then tries
to get the results so then and I
carburation collaboration with Dan over
the years we have taught each other a
lot and our views and strengths are very
similar even though they are colored in
some way so that's why we have written
this book called the easy strength and
so easy strength was about making
yourself strong for your sport not
making lifting your priority that's what
easy strength is about and out just
since you brought it up what are some of
the things that you've you've what would
be an example or examples of things
you've learned from dan dan has a
terrific concept of the quadrants the
four quadrants on one grid you're going
to see the level of development the
level on the other one you're going to
see the level of specialization it's
really quite hard to explain that over
over audio but if you look out type in
Dan John and
one said it's a terrific concept so what
that allows you to do is it allows you
to place yourself today in the
particular quadrant according to your
status according to your goals and
select the correct type of training for
yourself that alone is going to save
years of preparation for you so that's
just one of the many things then and I
have exchanged these little tactical
tidbits and details over the years and I
highly recommend Dan Jones work to
anybody anybody was an athlete or
anybody who thinks of himself or herself
as an athlete and I'd love to you I want
to personally give a few examples of
just how quickly or how significantly
you can shave off what people assume is
required to make massive gains you
introduced me to Barry Ross in Los
Angeles and the that became the
effortless superhuman chapter in the
4-hour body and I was able to put I'd
have to say it it must have been between
100 and 150 pounds on my deadlift in
less than three months I mean it was it
was just it was crazy and particularly
when you consider the inputs or the
total amount of time under tension and
an actual lifting frequency and time it
was did it really I've seen just given
that we are cut from the same cloth and
that we try to distill very complex
things and and use 80/20 analysis and so
on I've seen a lot of disproportionate
outputs for inputs but it really just it
really blew me away and the the testing
of assumptions where in that particular
case it's a deadlift based protocol
that's using what many people would
consider the weakest range of motion so
from the floor up to the knees
effectively really impressed me and then
to highlight your a couple of the points
you made earlier the the crushing with
the grip and the the ABS and the glutes
I recall when I did our kc1 and our
Casey - for those people not familiar
the Russian kettlebell certification one
and two which was a tremendous a
tremendously positive experience for me
and we did - and
encountering max-planck if I'm getting
that that is his last name right uh Mike
am I getting that right is that max big
max he was a believable Eve that that's
the fellow that his name is it's coming
to mind but there were there were few
people yourself included who I did not
pass all of the tests for arm Casey to
the first time around and one of them if
I'm remembering correctly was cleaning
and pressing a kettlebell that's roughly
half your body weight and I I was I
guess I ultimately made the three
attempts and I failed on the first two
attempts and with a few minor
Corrections just as moving my weight
slightly back towards the heels cleaning
with my elbow closer to basically
dropping my elbow a little bit lower and
then really focusing on the grip I was
able to press it and the third attempt
was felt easy and it was just
astonishing also some of the
demonstrations that you've done in front
of trainees where you've taken people
out of the crowd and said alright who's
somebody who would consider there and
I'm paraphrasing here but your your
maximum press X number of kilos and then
you'd bring them up and in front of
everyone in them in the within five
minutes or so you'd increase their press
by whatever might be five five kilos or
ten kilos you once mentioned to me in a
casual conversation I was I called you
for some type of training advice or it
might have been via email and correct me
from wrong we said when in doubt train
your grip in your core is that good
could you elaborate on that because I
think it's that's very it's not advice
that many people have received well Tim
there is such a thing is called the
irradiation so the phenomenon of
irradiation what it really means is if
you contract a muscle the tension from
that muscle is going to spill over to
the neighborhood muscles so for your
listeners I'd like to try this make a
fist
probably going to feel tense in your
forearm now make a tight fist you're
going to feel tension on your biceps
triceps now make a white-knuckle fist
you're going to find that tension is
going to spread into your shoulder you
latch it back and so on okay folks you
may relax now
and the same thing happens so certain
areas of the body have this great great
overflow of tension so the gripping
muscles are amongst them why in part
because they have such a great
representation in your nervous system in
your brain and as for the abs and as for
the glutes that has a lot to do with
creating your internal pressure so what
is this mean exactly
visualize your muscles as speakers and
visualize your brain as the gadget that
plays in music whatever it is these days
iPad iPhone whatever and the record
player doesn't matter and the amount of
your pressure the pressure in your
abdomen they drop down on the pressure
that's the amplifier that's a volume
control so by increasing the pressure in
your abdomen it's like you're training
up the volume and vice versa so when
you're trying to stretch when increasing
your flexibility if you see somebody
they're trying to do is split and you
see it's the person is creating high
intra-abdominal pressure and that just
increases the tension of the muscle
instead what you need to do you need to
now completely release and let go and
bring it down
so for strength we'll do the opposite we
have special techniques where you
increase that pressure and maximize your
power so that's those are just a couple
of the different ways we can increase
his strength and that's what you've seen
in my certification fYI I am no longer
with that organization so right my
company today is called strong first and
SMD certification that's that same
curriculum that you have that you have
learned by that and the just to to touch
on two points then we're going to jump
into more training and ask about how you
would rank certain aspects of what
people would traditionally consider
perhaps fitness the what would be a good
what would you what would you recommend
as good methods for developing the grip
and
core or abdomen for for those people
listening if they wanted to take a
simple protocol and perhaps experiment
for the next few weeks
what is is there any basic approach that
you might suggest for those two things
certain it can be done in conjunction
with a full-body training regimen that
uses let's say kettlebells climbing
ropes and so on but if it is not then
what I'd recommend that you do is you
get some grippers so the company is
called iron mind iron mind calm and they
carry hen grippers one thing you need to
understand is these are not those little
[ __ ] plastic grippers you get at a you
get at a store these are heavy-duty
grippers they go up to 365 pounds
there's a couple people in the world
have done that and they also do have
they also do have resources on how to do
that but even without reading how I can
tell you how to train so get yourself a
couple of Gerber's use their chart the
recommendations that are in mind offers
and start training them in the manner
that I referred to as grease the group
grease the group is a highly simplified
training methodology that's been derived
from Soviet weightlifting methodology so
in a nutshell this is what you do
throughout the day every day whenever
you feel fully recovered so you have to
have at least 15 minutes of rest between
sets
you know maybe 30 maybe even more is
you're going to do a set and you're only
going to do about half the repetitions
that you're capable of so for example
you picked up a particular gripper you
start squeezing and you probably could
do it ten times but you only do five
when you put it down let's say you later
on pick up a gripper that's a little
heavier maybe you could do three reps
with it but you don't want and in this
particular manner you accumulate reps
and you keep going and going and going
and everybody tells you that's
impossible to get strong in this
particular manner yet science and
experience shows that this makes you
strong this makes you strong fast this
makes you strong in a safe manner
and this makes you can apply this
particular methodology again I called
Teresa group to any strength exercise or
any strength endurance exercise just to
give you an example of its effectiveness
my father-in-law former Marine at the
age of 64 started following this routine
he was able to do about 10 pull-ups at
that point in several months he was up
to 20 what he tested and he could not do
that many as a young jarhead so you
young bucks out there you can definitely
get this done so this is how you guys
are going to train your grip with these
grippers carry through with you
throughout the day you're not going to
get sweaty just whenever you feel like
it just take it out and squeeze as for
training your abdomen there are many
different methods of training the
abdomen but you have to abide by the
following rules you have to keep the
repetitions to 5 and under no more than
five reps anything more than 5 reps is
bodybuilding and you need to make a
focus and tension might make a focus on
contraction as opposed to on reps and
fatigue just to give you an example of
the plank know the plank is a kind of a
fashionable exercise in the core
training circles and by the way we don't
use the word core that's drawn first why
don't we use the word cord because well
because people use the word cord they do
things we don't like we don't like it
though so we just say we just say
midsection and so the plank
so traditionally they would put you in
the plank and you're supposed to stay in
this plan for a couple minutes and
what's happening is you see this poor
person who cannot have been assume the
proper posture to start with and then s
fatigue sets in other muscles wrong
muscles start kicking and the back
starts arching the bus start shooting up
and what you're doing is what great
coupe calls putting Fitness that type of
dysfunction and what we do instead is if
we do a plank we call the hardstyle
plank we would do a plank for no longer
than 10 seconds and when you do the
plank you try to contract everything
absolutely everything when I showed that
everything I'm doing this shins your
forearms your neck everything everything
but your neck and face everything
below your neck you're going to contract
it's not for folks with high blood
pressure heart condition and that's true
for pretty much any type of training but
for everybody else is an extremely
powerful tool so you get down in a plank
you make fists okay you can touch your
abs you can check your glutes
you can trench your entire body you
pretend that somebody's walking in a
walk by and kick you in the ribs which
again somebody might be pleased with my
course and Andy Bolton and other top
power lifters still I've taught this
technique they swear by this because
this is the abdominal training for
strength this is not just some nonsense
that you do cranking out the reps so to
sum up your abdominal trick find
whatever abdominal exercises that you
like it can be the plank it can be some
kind of a setup it can be something from
your book the 4-hour body it can be
something from my book the hearts the
labs it can be something else that's not
important as long as it's a good
actually size that's been recognized
that it does work and three times a week
do 3 to 5 sets of 3 to 5 reps ok folks
just remember this 3 to 5 sets of 3 to 5
reps focus and contraction don't focus
on fatigue don't focus on the wraps and
I promise if you do these two things for
several months
you work your grip in this matter you
work your abs in this matter everything
that you do today is going to be
stronger I don't care what it is it's a
bigger deadlift it's a tennis serve it
makes no difference you're going to be
stronger and in the case of the the ab
let's just the the the midsection and
we're working with the plank if people
decided they were going to keep it
simple just so they can remember it and
do three sets of three reps three times
a week let's just say Monday well the
plank loads through just three sets of
ten seconds got excessive 10 SEC at 10
seconds three times a week
yes and try to contract everything below
your neck got it and I just is a as
further exhibit Exhibit A I've always
had and I'd be curious to dissect this
just for a second but I've always had
difficulty with
I have a relatively strong poll from say
the floor lay in large part thanks to
wrestling and other types of strength
training but also the barry ross
protocol when it comes to pulling myself
up to a bar though i can i can use
weight for low repetitions but i've
never been able to do higher repetitions
very well and I did this greasing the
groove walking around San Francisco for
a few weeks where any time I passed
construction scaffolding I would jump up
and there enough crazy people in San
Francisco fortunately or unfortunately
that it didn't really raise any eyebrows
or like I was just some crazy guy doing
pull-ups with a backpack whatever and I
would do two or three pull-ups and then
I just continued on my way and it was it
was astonishing I didn't really test my
max repetitions but how how much my
velocity I guess my the equivalent of
bar speed increased over that period of
time it really became much much more
explosive it was it was just astonishing
and but for people who have perhaps
trouble with higher repetition pull-ups
how would you troubleshoot that ultimate
guess first of all depends on high
repetitions mean if is if your goal is
20 or 25 strict pull-ups yeah let's
let's lose then yes that's one thing
because if you go beyond that and in
Russian Lee in Russia they even have
specialized competitions where they do
strip clubs for some crazy insane wraps
then training becomes so weird and so
state-of-the-art then you better not
even bother right but most people don't
need to do that so if you want to be
able to do 20 or 25 pull-ups you can
achieve that level purely by training a
strength which means that you never even
have to do more than five reps and
training and just whenever you go out
and test then you're going to get those
reps here's something yours and note
about strength endurance the more
resistance that you're overcoming in
your endurance effort the more strength
helps so what does that mean it means
that if you're strong that is let's say
you have a good debt
that's going to help you carry beer kegs
to the second floor but on the other
hand it's not necessarily going to help
you hammering a nail all day that makes
any sense
Rico's hammers light beer kegs are heavy
so when you're doing a 25 repetition
effort the weight is significant it's
the significant percentage of your 1 rep
max so that can be bumped up purely just
by by getting stronger so that would be
my recommendation for people who have a
hard time doing pull-ups to start with I
would recommend start by learning to get
tight through their abs that's very
important there's an article a couple
years ago saying that women cannot do
co-op switches of course absolute
nonsense in strong first organization we
have some ladies who can do you know we
have a lady in Boston Amanda Perry who
can do strict dead hang 14 pull-ups
neck to the bar so the way we do
pull-ups is no tipping no swinging
pausing between the bottom and you have
to touch your neck to the bar so she can
do 14 for example she's my all molested
at the edge it much better men than most
men and just wait just for those people
who have not tried this up having gone
through some of this training with pop
if you have just done if the difference
between doing a strict pull-up or what
you envision to be a strict pull-up
where you kind of throw your chin up
above the bar height versus pulling in
to touch your neck slowly to the bar it
is so different as to it's not a
difference in degree it's sort of a
difference in species but anyway yes I
challenge I challenge everyone to try it
it's really challenging well doing for
people who offer people who have a hard
time just to get started in pull-ups and
again that's true for some ladies many
ladies that's true for a number of
gentleman as well a lot of the problem
is they're unable to contract the
abdominals strongly enough they aren't
able to even assume the strong posture
remember I told you earlier that I
reverse engineer with a strong
naturally so if you watchin gymnasts
perform any kind of maneuvers and their
rings let's say you will see something
called the hollow position so what's the
hollow position the hollow position is
the body is like your tail is tucked in
and your body kind of forms a it's like
a dish your body looks like a dish
pretty much so if you want to learn to
do clubs first you need to master the
hollow position it's very easy for you
to type in it type it into your search
engine the hollow position find a
picture see what it looks like and just
practice this hollow position this
hollow Rock listen dexterous is called
the hollow Rock I explained it in my
book hardstyle abs but I'm sure you can
find it anywhere else and so you
practice this hollow Rock and this
hollow Rock is going to not only
strengthen your abs but it's also going
to teach you how to acquire that
position and then after that you can
start working with assisted reps and
that's a very big difference we're not
talking about negatives we're not
talking about four straps we're talking
about assistance reps a sista traps so
what's the difference the difference is
an assisted rep feels like a moderately
challenging rep that you do on your own
so your training partner or your trainer
is going to push you in your mid-back
and enable you to do that with some
degree of difficulty but definitely not
make a struggle and when they've done
the study on young gymnasts years ago in
the Soviet Union and they use this type
of methodology they called it artificial
controlling environment where the
partner allows you to do a perfect
repetition but in a way that doesn't
really kill you it doesn't make you
struggle they found that the speed with
which they progress was absolutely
remarkable so practicing your hollow
Rock don't forget you're at grip and
then start three times a week with the
help of your training partner do let's
say three to five sets of three to five
reps of assistant assisted pull-ups and
I just want to reiterate again the low
reps are key guys if you want to be
strong you need to keep your reps at
five and under
and at five reps rounder is what you're
really working on sort of the it's and
I'll get out of my depth and into yours
pretty quickly but the sort of neural
pathways and the recruit the recruitment
of motor neurons and sort of firing
capabilities and so on pretty much
you're going to have you're going to
have a high level of neural adaptations
and you're also going to build some
muscle as well so you're going to build
the high threshold motor units as well
but not it's not a bodybuilding protocol
you will build some muscle but it's not
really the end then goal itself so you
were trying to also you trying to avoid
the fatigue you're trying to avoid the
burn because when I restart experiencing
the burn that's from something called
hydrogen ions that leads to a whole lot
of problems for you so one of the
problems is it interferes with the
command that your brain can sense to the
muscle to contract and another problem
that it creates these hydrogen ions
literal or destructive so if you leave
them around the muscle for too long they
really start destroying your muscle so
just keep those reps under and 5 3 to 5
don't worry about getting bulkier and I
got a good buck it's not going to happen
and approach your training as a practice
so this is another very important point
tip I think this is a super important
point now I'm glad you're bringing this
up I hate the word workout the reward
workout does not exist in the Russian
language we talked about a training
session or we talked about a lesson we
never talked about a workout just think
of what does the word working out what
is it what do you envision sweating and
grunting and Doug see let's see let's
see how much I can punish myself and
drain myself so the goal is not to get
stronger the goal is just to get get
worn out and there are simpler ways of
doing that run up the mountain okay so
no the idea here is practice strength is
a skill and as such it must be practice
and if you approach it in this matter
not only you're going to get stronger so
much faster but you're going to truly
enjoy your training process training
should be something that should be
enjoyed now I this this this ring so
true to me and it was really a
revelation
just coming from the masochistic world
of the few sports that I practice and
certainly did not get to a world-class
level but competed on a national level
in a few different sports and the the
mind shift from depleting your reservoir
or reserves as much as possible to
identifying the skills and practicing
them even if you feel better at the end
of a workout than at the beginning it
was really a huge shift for me in a few
places certainly in strength training I
think that you bury Ross's protocol was
eye-opening in so much as just like you
mentioned put 100 I think it was around
120 this is all detailed in the 4-hour
body so I'm losing the specifics but
about about 120 pounds on my max
deadlift through the exit through the
full range of motion not just the range
in which we were practicing in a short
period of time and gained fewer than 10
pounds of additional muscle and you
probably enjoyed your training loved it
it was just amazing I mean felt on fire
I mean partially because you're you're
you know blowing a fog horn into your
nervous systems ear let me to it but the
the other area and I think this this is
such a fantastic principle that applies
to so many different areas was in the
world of swimming and some people might
recall if they followed my stuff for a
while that I was not able to swim a lap
in a proper pool until I was in my 30s
and what what really shifted the mindset
completely was going from swimming
workouts and and hiring coaches who
viewed it that way to looking at Total
Immersion where they really focus on the
skill of deconstructing the biomechanics
of swimming challenging the assumptions
of how swimming is taught and it became
this really joyful wonderful experience
and I was able to go from basically zero
laps to sort of 20 laps per practice in
less than ten days so it's it's such an
important shift and I'm glad you brought
it up which which kind of leads me to
the next the next question that and it's
about prioritization so when people
think of fitness at particularly non
athletes
I think that there tends to be a very
scattershot approach and there's a
paradox of choice challenge that they
have where they're they're fed a lot of
recommendations from many different
people and they have strengths let's
just talk this strength not necessarily
muscle gain but just getting stronger
they have hypertrophy so increasing
their the muscular size for lack of a
better description endurance flexibility
how would you rank these in order of
priority and why Tim as long as the
person has their required mobility and
symmetry the priority is always at
health the priority is always strength
strength has to be first so the first
step that you do is you I assess your
mobility you find specialist who can do
that
FMS would be FMS would be a
recommendation of mine very coups FMS
functional movement screen functional
movement screen is going to find out how
mobile you are and also how symmetrical
you are so as long as that is dialed in
that is in place you have to get strong
and strength is the mother quality of
all physical qualities and that's not a
statement by me that's a statement by
participative
the father of fertilization one of the
greatest for scientist ever and greater
strength increases your performance in
absolutely everything so you can see of
course okay of course yet being stronger
is going to help you and let's say
punching somebody harder lifting
something but how is that going to help
me if I am let's say a triathlete how's
that gonna help me find a marathon
runner it is going to help you in
several different ways one is the
perceived level of exertion is going to
go down several years ago Norwegians did
a very interesting study where they put
elite endurance athletes some were
bicyclist some were runners on a pure
strength regimen does four sets of four
reps of heavy squats
it's about as pure strength is against
and in the end of this study not
surprisingly all these guys were
stronger they could jump higher and so
on but they were
not impressed with that that didn't
matter to them what did impress them is
it ran faster
there are times their race times went
down because strength just makes enables
everything else if you're trying to
let's say lose weight being stronger is
going to help you do that because you're
going to have you're going to have have
a bigger furnace you're going to train
yourself much harder and the exercises
that are fat loss exercises so it really
doesn't matter what it is that you're
trying to achieve strength is the number
one attribute you need to address and
that's why my company is called strong
first you know yeah I love I love that
the the you one of the things that I
love about you probable is that you say
what you mean and mean what you say and
I I just it there's that there's this
there's a degree of clarity that I inv
and I might include it for people but
the when we did our sound check I asked
you to do you know to give me an answer
so we could test the audio what you had
for breakfast and what was your answer
coffee and that was it that was the
sound check yeah I love this the the
simplicity now speaking of simplicity
and also sort of undoing the confusion
that a lot of people suffer from what
are what are the most counterproductive
myths or misconceptions about strength
training that come to mind well the
number one to my guess is the idea that
you have to go to failure mm-hm every
time you train right and I can tell you
one thing that the Soviet weight lifters
I I have done a very thorough analysis
of the Soviet weightlifting methodology
from through the 60s through the 80s the
glory days and I found that they
typically did 1/3 to 2/3 of maximal
repetitions per set so what does it mean
if let's say that you're using a weight
that's your 10 rep max 10 is all you
could do if you put yourself very hard
they would do three to six consistently
now you probably ask yourself okay I'm
not a weightlifter and what does this so
get stuff from the 80s have to do with
today
well two things first of all even though
a person who is not at lifting athlete
is not going to train exactly as a
weightlifter a power lifter nevertheless
the methodology has to be derived from
the sports because these are specialist
strength sports so if they just have to
be adapted to your needs
second of all the this particular Soviet
methodology is still superior to this
day this is very interesting but if you
you keep hearing about all this new
world records set in the sport of
weightlifting well if you compare the
world records of today to the world
records of the 80s you will see that in
most cases the records today are
inferior to records in the 80s how can
that be they accuse people of doing
drugs and they changed weight classes
twice since the 80s of course it's so
wonderful I'm so happy that today nobody
does drugs anymore it's just terrific if
you look at if you look at the lifts
performed by Soviet lifter ud Klavan
young in 1980 at the Moscow Olympics
this lifts have never been exceeded
these lives have never been approached
so this particular methodology does work
extremely well it's still the best
methodology period later on the Soviet
power lifting team adapted this
methodology for part of thing with
tremendous success the Dinan a and the
same particular methodology has been
adapted to bodyweight training
kettlebell presses and so on and so
forth so it's the same thing that can
apply for everybody because this is
principle based training so the major
misconception is that you have to go to
failure so that if you just overcome
that and if you make it a habit to do
1/3 to 2/3 of the repetitions they're
possible and do more sets instead you're
gonna make much greater progress you're
going to do much safer and folks you can
enjoy your training and how do how does
the approach shift if your focus is
maximal hypertrophy if you're after
maxima hypertrophy it's Molly
so they've figured out in the Soviet
Union that there's a direct correlation
between volume and hypertrophy so you
just pretty much have to do more sets
you're going to have to do more sets in
like sixty to seventy percent of your
max range and a whole bunch of sets of
five and six just many of them and your
rest periods might be compressed a
little more but that's it if you do that
do this a couple times a week many sets
of five or six don't want to worry about
how many just just keep going don't kill
yourself enjoy yourself eat more you're
going to get bigger it's unavoidable
it's just as simple as that and if I've
of course I've I've spoken with with
fans and written about the app the
applications of to failure training for
primarily hypertrophy just because
you're doing so much with the sarcoplasm
and maximizing the sort of cellular
volume that the the challenge is not so
much the training with hypertrophy it's
the eating it's just I mean you really
you feel like the the Japanese hotdog
eater called by Oishi after a while it's
just waking up in the middle of the
night to eat meals and whatnot it's a
that that's by far the most punishing
aspect of for me at least it is assume
it is and any tricks there's nobody
knows also nobody knows the other couple
tricks but they're no I'll mention them
in a second and nobody does know exactly
what happens in the cellular level when
you try to stimulate muscle hypertrophy
now anybody who tells you that they know
they you know it's just speculation at
best there are a number theory some of
the theories are more credible than
others but the fact is we still do not
know and what makes his Soviet
weightlifting methodology of the 80s so
spectacular is that was a purely
empirical methodology they tried to
explain what happens in the cellular
level but they didn't try too hard it
was pretty much a trial and error they
would analyze the training logs of
successful literature
and successful competitions they analyze
this data they made recommendations and
it's kind of chicken-and-egg where does
it start
scientists watching what the best
lifters do or the best lifters the best
scientists telling the best lifters what
to do it was kind of both and they kept
narrowing down narrowing down narrowing
it down and this is how it works but we
still don't know exactly what happens
there what is your I wanted I definitely
want to touch on the the tricks for not
making yourself nauseous all day when
you're trying to to pack on pounds of
muscle but before that what is your
favorite pet theory what even if it's
speculative at this point what is your
preferred theory for muscular growth
okay budget by thousand cuz theory makes
most sense to me and according to this
theory when the muscle comes the
contraction comes to an end or close to
an end when you have depleted the
creatine phosphate in the muscle that's
the primary stimulus for hypertrophy
according to him and again what could
that possibly well how can that possibly
do in if the muscle contraction stops
not as a result of mounting acidity and
that's very very important but as a
result of there is simply not not
created phosphate supposedly the cross
bridges no longer can really disengage
properly so supposing my cross producers
have met them the - that's right
supposedly this is what terrorism apart
suppose so that's what causes the micro
trauma that makes it satellite cells do
their thing so that's one fairly
credible explanation I don't know if
this is true or not but training in my
experience that Protestants can practice
on because approach to training were you
gonna hit it pretty hard this set would
probably be about twenty thirty seconds
in duration if you're trying to target
your highest partial motor units and
then you're going to have to stop and
you have to rest a long time between the
between the sets
so this it does make a lot of sense
there is another theory that works
fairly well with it
professor Victoza Liana according to him
the role of creatine phosphate here is
once you deplete your creatine phosphate
and you do have a lot of free creatine
which is you know pretty much by-product
what that does is makes the membrane of
the cell permeable to the hormones
anabolic hormones very interesting
so what's he Leonov says there are four
prerequisite to muscle hypertrophy one
is obvious is that's the presence of
amino acids the second is the presence
of anabolic hormones which obviously has
to do with the capacity or and the
current system but also your training as
well training stress does seem to do
that and third is the presence of free
creatine as again the same thing that
free creatine is a lot of recruit and is
formed when the muscle is pushed hard
but not before it gets a city and
finally the fourth one is the presence
of hydrogen ions not not for too long
so I get hydrogen ions it's again it's a
something that you get out of muscle
contraction any muscle contraction and
the service that they do for muscle
hypertrophy
according to see Leonov is just like the
free creatine they make the membrane
more permeable to the hormones so then
then what happens is this hormones which
are pretty much messengers they go into
the cell and as they go into the cell
they have get the whole process of
transcription translation you know
protein synthesis is going the also very
interesting element of Juliano's theory
and cellulose methodology and again
something that sits well with me I'm
having observed training effective
training is very long rest periods
between sets so see leonov recommends 5
to 10 minutes of rest between the sets
and that at rest has to be active so you
pretty much have to move around so you
don't just you don't just sit you just
move you wave your arms you kind of
shake your muscles
shake your legs you walk and that's
supposed to get rid of the clear out the
hydrogen is as quickly as possible
because having them there briefly is
good having them there for too long it's
not good because it literally
destructive it's a charged particle
that's what it is and so they're walking
or are they on stationary bikes on like
an Ariel ions you don't need a
stationary bike you just pretty much
want to walk there are there's a
particular type of relaxation exercises
Tim we're going fast and loose exercises
to all the Russian athletes do so pretty
much what they are is if you may
remember my chemical certification I had
people standing kind of shake out the
arms and legs right so you just pretty
much shake your arms and legs and you
just walk around that's that's pretty
much what you do so that's that is
Giuliana's theory which also seems to
make sense
notice that in both cases where there's
fantastical cursory silly Yanis you are
going to push yourself much closer to
failure to rep next so when you're
training just for strength you don't
need to do that you just do 1/3 to 2/3
of your maximum reps when you're trying
to train for hypertrophy yes you can do
just simply more submaximal sets but
sometimes you just have to push yourself
harder not to failure still but harder
and Juliana falso has the most
fascinating slow twitch fiber protocol
as well I'd like to tell you readers
about it because there a lot of
misconceptions about training the slow
fibers well if you think about slow
fiber as well which most people
associate with endurance yeah exactly
and they do have endurance that's true
but they're also people think well
they're thin they're weak they're small
and why should I do that why would any
self-respecting power athletes you know
demean himself training slow cars so and
juliana has a very different point of
view on this first of all if you look at
back in the 6th in some studies done at
the 60s if you compare the strength of
your slow fibers and fast ones they are
just as strong for the same
cross-section so which means that if you
have a bundle of slow fibers that's as
thick as your finger and you have a
bundle of fast fibers that's as thick as
your finger they're equally strong just
you know this lower bundle is going to
have more
Moeller fibers but it doesn't matter
number one number two because their
velocity of contraction for the fast
fibers can be twenty forty percent
higher for the slow fibers the
presumption is well I need to move fast
I can't afford that so but see Liana's
work has found out that even in sprint
fifty percent of the output is provided
by slow fibers and he says even though
in vitro that may be true that these
fibers are contracting faster but in
vivo in real life in sport activities
you're not really going to go so fast so
that advantage is no longer no longer
valid he has put experienced printers on
a training protocol that hypertrophied
their slow fibers and these sprinters
improved their sprint 400 meters on
average from ten point nine seconds to
ten point seven just formed just from
this slow fast slow fibre hypertrophy
and there is additional benefits of
hyper drift for slow fibers something
can discuss a little bit later if we
talk about if you choose to talk about
endurance is these sole fibers come pre
equipped with mitochondria which means
they have a lot of endurance so for
other types of athletes that can be very
beneficial so see Leonov has this
fascinating training protocol for
training for hypertrophy of slow fibers
so here's how these skills he says the
biggest problem that you have is
typically people just try to go and burn
them out well but all that does again
that just the gig comes to an end
because of the mounting acidity that's
not the right stimulus right there you
want to make sure that you exhaust at
creating phosphate get that free
creative long so how do you do that you
create occlusion so he would have you do
set a clear conclusion that means
basically shut that with the contraction
prevents the blood flow it's a constant
tension what bodybuilders would call
concept tension and what you would do is
you would do let's say squats you go a
little bit below parallel you go a
little bit above parallel you're going
slow the timeframe is 30 to 60 seconds
that the duration and you have to come
to failure close to failure now
this is again this is what's really
fascinating after that and this is
what's so different from the traditional
slow to his training is you have to take
that same 5 to 10-minute active rest
because he says if you don't that
mounting acidity is going to mess
everything out and on one day a week
typically you would do four to nine sets
in this matter and then three to four
days later you do a second day where you
do one to three sets so that's a
protocol one more time super slow
movement no rest thirty to sixty seconds
in duration one day a week four to nine
sets three to four days later one to
three sets five to ten minutes of rest
in between active rest by the way active
rest can also mean work in different
muscle groups that's that's very fine as
well and just to tell you how effective
this protocol is he put a number of
athletes experienced athletes from
different sports on who knew how to
squat on a back squat protocol using
these music things these types of reps
and sets and so on and in eight weeks
these guys increased more than added
more than 25% of their back squat holy
crap yeah yeah and you can realize these
guys were not these guys were not your
typical American College subjects you
know the guys with very fast thumbs you
know Facebook people know I'm talking
I'm talking about athletes and what what
percentage of their one rep max were
they using for these thirty to sixty
Seconds sets because that's it that's a
challenging micro range of movement okay
it
the typical guidelines you have to find
it for yourself because that depends on
your butt on your fiber composition
right typically it's about thirty to
sixty percent for your lower body and
ten to forty percent for your body so
why is the difference and the difference
is is determined by the fact that your
upper body is more fest which so if you
look at an average person an average
person is going to have about 70 percent
fast which fibers in that per body and
the lower body about 50/50 but so you
have to use a lighter weight relatively
speaking for the upper body to stay in
that timeframe I see got it but it's a
trial and error to is just try a little
no
what would people what would you suggest
they Google or search for to learn more
about this nothing I'm afraid
but I think that Shh and that that means
don't search for quote nothing I'm
afraid that means you can't search for
it but I'm going to if you listen very
carefully to what I said they should
have no problem doing that I can give
you a couple of exercises other
exercises that you can do so for the
lower body you can use the back squat or
you can use the front squat and for the
upper body you could use something like
the Diamond push-ups for the triceps and
what you need to do is you need to
adjust the difficulty based on adjust
the elevation let elevate your hands if
you want it easier elevate your feet you
want to make it harder but again the
idea is to come to failure it's rooted
thirty to sixty Seconds and for the
push-up you're going to do work in the
mid-range so you're never going to come
to lockout you never going to come to
the bottom you're going to slowly keep
working keep working through that
mid-range
if you want to do this for the upper
body it's probably the best idea would
be some kind of a rowing machine and
again you're going to be working through
the mid-range or curls I hate to say it
but yes curls silicon of sea Leonov has
been extremely successful with athletes
from very diverse sports he's worked
with national team for judo [ __ ]
full-contact karate a bicycle racing
soccer and these guys have seen terrific
terrific results from this so you guys
may want to give it a try that's the the
the fascinating the most unexpected
aspect of that for me is the the five to
10-minute rest sets that's really
fascinating and I should also add love
to underscore one thing for people and
please correct me Paul if I'm getting
this incorrect but a lot of folks think
about the burn as being a product of
lactate or lactic acid but it's it's
actually a byproduct where as a side
effect primary effect of the hydrogen
ions that you were talking about it is
and I think that that has a lot of there
are some swelling some nerve endings are
yeah yeah it doesn't it really folks it
really doesn't matter the only thing
that you need to realize is this on this
particular training protocol you go
for this burn this burn is needed the
important things that burn is over after
30 or 60 seconds and then you try to get
rid of as fast as possible and for other
types of training if you're trying to
train for strength
you want to trying to avoid the burn
altogether the burn is the burn is your
enemy it's a two to two questions on the
details here the first is if if free
creatine I guess that's just free
creatine in in serum Bala and I could be
wrong on that is one of the stimuli that
that produces the the training
adaptation can you accelerate that or
even catalyze it with supplemental use
of creatine monohydrate for instance
yeah absolutely
okay and then the second question is
related to the what some people have
called the golden era of steroids which
was the 80s right so that I guess what
I'm very curious to know is why have the
why the Soviets changed their approach
or what has caused the what is what has
prevented them from attaining or
surpassing the records of the 80s and
understood obviously that athletes are
still using many different types of
performance-enhancing drugs but what has
changed or and why did the change in Tim
I think Dan Gianna has said it really
well he'd work so well I got bored with
it and I stopped doing it yeah and
before shortly before their death not
you know in the last decade both Vicey
galaxies if it was a great champion and
Akagi vibe UF was a great champion and
the sport scientists they criticize
these practices very very heavily alexei
medev a Jif who also has done the same
thing they said basically you guys are
barking up the wrong tree right here so
I just think that people trying to get
fancy it's funny that's what's happening
in Russia is probably reflecting that
whole trend Western trend that's messing
Talib
to call new amania people loved in you
yeah people just absolutely love the new
there they're forgetting that what stuff
that it worked much better you could
consider the results the results were
superior back then the same thing you
can look at the powerlifting methodology
the also going back to the 80s the
classic American powerlifting
methodology the classic cycling as
exemplified by lifters like Edie cone
and Lamar Gant and systematized by Marty
Gallagher again people are saying well
we have better training methods these
days and they're showing you different
numbers of the squats and the bench
press and so on to which I said well in
the squat on the bench press it has
become impossible to really compare
apples and apples because of all this
crazy shirts and she's like you are
wearing exactly but in the deadlift
you're still seeing look at the record
tables the record table is a number of
the deadlift records are still set back
in the 80's and 90's and they're still
sitting these are old-time historic
records and even the advancement of some
assistance gear for the deadlift and
advancement of the longer bars with
their bars and so on yet improved some
polls but still many of these records
still do stand and the 80s is a
fascinating era for strength I wrote a
blog a little while ago that I called it
forward to the past it was inspired by
the upcoming 30th anniversary of the
movie Back to the Future and the point
and the point I made in there look you
know if Marty McFly wanted to travel
there plenty of reasons to travel to
today's day but looking for strength
advice that he would have been much
better off staying home because it's so
did not weight lifting with the
knowledge of the 80s that American power
lifting with the Dodge of the 80s this
tool remains superior and that's not
something you can argue yeah ed Khan
even for people who are not familiar
perhaps especially for people who are
not familiar with powerlifting I think
would just be fascinated by by Ed Cohn
what was it he pulled god I'm blanking
here
9:01 probably is used best a little
button I will add as well Lottie wait
those money I wanted to 20 those costs
and edy has said at his cents I worked
close to a hundred World Records in and
he has competed in weight classes you
know so many different weight classes
over the years and he also had a
remarkably injury-free career just
really remarkably his hips gave him I
mean he said these had hip issues since
then do you think that's a result of
sumo style deadlift I doubt it very much
you do I doubt it very much I mean deep
squat if you if you talk to somebody
like great cook if you talk to somebody
professor stuart mcgill you will find
that deeper wide squats could pop
probably to some problems sumo deadlift
it's extremely extremely unlikely very
interesting and one of the things that
by the way Tim sorry to interrupt you
how many people do you know who don't
sumo deadlift anything heavier than the
newspaper I have to go get get the
against replace no exactly and this is
actually something I was going to bring
up which is when people see the Lyle
Alzado knows of the world the
bodybuilders should get cancer and they
go oh my god you know the steroids cause
cancer and it's like well you have to
look at in the context of how many
people out of a thousand would get
cancer whether they're in the gym or
injecting steroids or not to really have
a fair assessment of causal factors
right so I so your points well-taken the
thing the the Freud job sure I'll
interrupt you though I will say once now
keep interrupting any of these guys many
of these guys who competed a very high
level in the 80s and the 70s are very
healthy and doing extremely well
if you look at Gallagher himself he's
right now he's in his 60s he is very
strong very spry fully healthy hikes in
the woods you know every day if you look
at weight lifters well forget the 80s
let's go back a little farther a little
bit of Brook failure he was at his
soviet-german
he was Olympic champion in weightlifting
at the age of 37 and that's something
that's never been doing Incred been
replicated absolutely it is incredible
today he somewhere in his mid 80s
and every day as part of his training
regimen he does jump squats with 200
pounds 90 kilos oh so he goes rock
bottom the squat and jumps up and that's
a guy needs mid-80s and in fact he looks
so good
some some journalists came to interview
him and said uh excuse me sir may we
speak to your dad that's amazing Wow
something to aspire to I've been that
stunt on the weightlifter point I've
been spending time with an amazing
gentleman named Jersey Gregor Eck not
sure if that rings a bell but he is the
best is a very nice man he is a polish
or accomplished lifter very accomplished
world-class weightlifter I think
primarily in the masters division but
he's I'm speculating here probably in
his mix mid-60s I'm spending time with
him and he can still you know throw I
don't I went under the exact weight but
he had two to three hundred pounds over
his head in the snatch no problem Oh
doesn't he still can do a full split uh
he is
amazingly flexible I haven't asked him
to do any Van Damme type stuff for me
but his his ability his his hamstring
flexibility which of course is much more
than hamstrings but what I perceived
what a layperson would perceive as
hamstring flexibility just blows my mind
it's it's amazing how flexible this guy
is so it's it that's I'm very interested
in the long game so but increasingly
interested you know the older I get I'm
37
I can't I'm certainly not going to be
winning any Olympic gold medals anytime
soon and weight lifts my father took up
powerlifting at the age of 71 he's 77
today he dead lifted 413 pounds without
a belt and he said you know several
American Records in his age group and
over training for five years so he put
on 20 pounds of muscle if you look at my
father if you look at him from back you
will think that this guy's got to be in
his 40s and he looks like a wrestler he
has just been massive and Stu McGill
when he examine it says he's got he's
never seen such muscular development of
a 70 year old and he started when you 71
would you consider the and please
disagree if this is not the case but if
you had to pick one movement for
strength longevity would the deadlift be
that move of that movement or is it not
possible to choose one movement how do
you try to answer that question if you
were to choose one movement Tim yes I
would choose the deadlift or I would
choose the chemical swing obviously the
kettlebell swing is not something you
can compete in and something you're not
it's not going to give you that same
satisfaction lifting a heavy weight but
those are the two main full body
exercises the full body expressions of
power that will go such a long way for
you for longevity strength just the
quality of life other what are the
biggest mistakes that people make with
the deadlift whether that's technically
or in program and what are the the
biggest mistakes and not not asking you
to repeat things you've already said but
is there anything that top of mind that
well Tim I think the very big mistake is
because they think okay I have picked up
things from the floor this looks so
simple it's not an Olympic lifts
therefore it's very simple so let's just
start filing on place and start training
they delicate is a very technical lift
and even if you're just a recreational
lifter you owe it to yourself to learn
to dealt correctly so that's that's as
simple as that
so I say that's that's the primary
mistake and that mistake goes for every
exercise that people do out there yeah
and I would highly recommend people
check out your book with now I want to
say what with mr. Bolten Devin dynamite
yeah really
very very dense shifting gears just just
a little bit dense and the best way
possible
no no fluff ah I'd love to shift gears
and just ask you a few questions about
it sort of your philosophies and your
thinking not then not so much the the
highly specific training questions but
when you think of for instance the word
successful who's the first person who
comes to mind for you Tim I am fortunate
enough to know many
accessible people and I think that what
separation from the rest is the CEO of
strong first Eric for heart he put it
very well
he says balance with priorities balance
with priorities so Eric yourself and
many others are fortunate to know they
exemplify success for me and the how do
you have what is the best way what are
the habits that you've observed that
allowed people to have balance with
priorities what are the the things they
do that other people don't do alright
or maybe the things they don't do that
other people do well I think one is calm
these people are calm because this
people who are hyper they get sort of
trapped in their reactive mode they get
to trapped and they everyday minutia
their work in their existence so they
just do not pause and they do not think
again Eric has a great quote from a
vietnam-era seal which says calm is
contagious calm is contagious so when
the person has come that he or she has
the time to meditate reflect set the
priorities and set the balance Yallop
that's certainly holds true from what
I've seen and the opposite of course is
true hysteria is why he's just chasing
the tail absolutely Chicken Little
this guy's fallen yes everything is
urgent
sounds like the Internet and a nutshell
right there huh the UH
what do you have any morning rituals
what is you what are the what are the
first what is the first hour or two of
your day look like typically
I like to ease into my day I will get up
early 6:00 a.m. typically and my wife
and I will just have coffee and read the
newspaper and make small talk I really
take my time i pointedly read a paper
not watch TV not to get any kind of
electronic news or radio I really
appreciate the calm of print because
whenever you're watching TV it's just
the latest news there breaking news and
it's again it's same tail-chasing asked
after that if I if I decide to the train
with kettlebells I'll go to the beach
and do that if I do not do that this
morning
I'll just still go to the beach for half
an hour what time I was willing that'll
probably be about seven o'clock and I
will take a dip I'll meditate a little I
might stretch a little
so it's against a time to time to be
composed after that it's a time to do
creative work so I will either write or
I will do research and when I do that I
very pointedly have the email down so my
whole email application is down if I
need to use the internet for some
research you know the browser will stay
up but not the email and my colleagues
know to call me if they have something
urgent and not a lot of people call me
because I have my business card only as
my email so that's good no I so does it
have your email and it says please call
if ur a virgin number no he doesn't know
my obviously might count did you have
that so and when I write I will
sometimes change the environment I'd
like to go to a coffee shop or go to a
park or something and I do have a
particular method when I when I write so
I will just select some topic and I work
in this topic and as soon as I hit the
wall on this topic I just switch to
something else I never fight the right
at writer's block to noon I just
absolutely I just have a lot of
different things a lot of different
projects chapters articles books
whatever going at the same time and I'm
very flexible about it and also do let
my books evolve and sometimes they
evolve in a very unpredictable manner
the naked warrior started out as a book
for strengthening the field for the
military and then it evolved in a sort
of a manifesto for reverse engineering
the body language of the strong so I
just kind of let that happen towards the
end of the day it's make a call make a
call with my coworkers take care of some
business dinner with my wife and you
know pretty much relax read some first
read some nonfiction then read some
fiction that's a pretty standard day
what I like my days I like the sound of
your days to the the do you listen to
music and if so what type of music what
are the most frequently played songs or
albums on your iPhone or my my music
tastes are I like the yin yang kind of
like stuff in the middle so on one hand
I enjoy 1980s heavy metal I like except
our maiden Saxon these are my favorite
bands on the other hand I will listen to
Jackson Browne Carla Bruni
Iman Tong so in my opinion music has to
be either you know yeah it's all ideas
on it's almost like everything yeah
exactly
seriously if you think a performance is
the same say the art of physical
performance is the art of turning on the
switch and shutting it up for maximal
strength you have to turn it a lot for
maximal flexibility and endurance you
have to turn it off and for a lot of
sports is the ability to turn it on and
off on and off back and forth back and
forth
attention relaxation so I do like these
extremes in my music so right so you're
either you're either Vivaldi or Pantera
and no nope no pop music and know this
stuff in the middle has no right to just
and uh when you're writing are you
writing do you write on a laptop
do you write and if so do you use word
or some other program or are you writing
in a journal
how are you jumping between these
various articles that you're working on
to my right and ward and what I do is I
have a very
peculiar type of organizational data in
my mind in my mind I have many different
shelves with many different projects and
many different research studies and so
on so I can kind of see in my mind what
connects with what I see the pattern so
I can go back and forth and I really
think that the computer doesn't Nabal me
to do that so much easier and I'm
generally not a fan of technology but I
have to say that the word processor it's
one piece of technology that's have a
very big fan I think on the page I don't
think in my mind I think of a page yeah
that's that's something that I've heard
from a number of good writers is that
they they have to write to clarify what
they're actually thinking it's not they
form the thought and put it down they
use the process of writing to clarify
their thinking do you do you have a
private journal or anything like that
you no you do not okay and just since I
love talking about this but I won't take
too long a recommendation that really
was a game changer for me is using a
program called Scrivener in place of
word and Scrivener is as it sounds what
that allows you to do it was originally
designed for movie scripts I believe for
screenwriting and what it allows you to
do is have all of your various documents
which would each otherwise be a separate
word file in a table of contents on the
left hand side of the screen which you
can move around and modify and put into
folders which I've used for all of my my
last three books and then you can look
at two different pieces of writing on
the right-hand side so what I'll
typically have is a folder that's all
research documents and and I will have a
split pane on the right side where the
top is what I'm working on what I'm
actually writing and the bottom right is
the research document so rather than
having a million windows open with
different Word documents and as you've
probably experienced once you have
enough of this open eventually it just
craps out on you and jumps off the cliff
I don't think I've ever had in however
many years I've used it Scrivener fail I
mean it's big
as it strips out a lot of the bloat but
you might really I don't think you I'll
definitely try it yeah it's it's a fun
program to play with and I don't have
the mental I have too many plates
spinning it once in terms of articles if
I'm working on a larger project like
books so Scrivener helps me to to codify
that which I find very helpful how do
you change your do you change your
typical routine on the weekends is there
anything that you do differently on the
weekends to decompress or otherwise not
a lot go to church go out go for a hike
with Moab Julie but otherwise pretty
much everyday I try to have a balance of
work balance of family balance of
recreation and a balance of
self-improvement speaking on the last
point self-improvement what are what are
what are things that you're currently
trying to or would like to improve about
yourself well about myself that that
would be private Tim you know I think
that it's just with just us girls just
between us you know I think that over
sharing is one of the major malfunctions
of the modern world so I think I'm going
to keep this one to myself but but I'm
going to tell you what I'm trying to
improve profession okay that's fine I
have as I mentioned again I have been
able to dissect the very successful
weightlifting methodology of the 60s and
through a 80s which is extremely complex
methodology and I've been able to bring
it down to the underlying principles and
codify it and write up hugger ifs so
what I'm what I'm doing right now is
trying to bring this very sophisticated
very amazing system of training to
regular people who just want to get
stronger so I am in this refinement
phase got it and so to touch on that
just is a segue I'd love to talk about
flexibility because I get a lot of
questions about flexibility I don't
consider it my area of expertise so I
constantly refer people to your work but
uh I'd love to hear you talk about
where flexibility fits into the picture
or when it does because I think for me
and for other people there's a lot of
confusion around mobility versus
flexibility one of the questions I get
most often for instance is how do I get
to the full side splits they want to go
between the chairs like Van Damme and
you know is that is that a a worthwhile
goal is it a terrible goal this is a lot
coming at you at one but how does
flexibility fit into the picture or not
for what types of people okay well first
of all let me tell you about the goal to
split whether each if you choose to
achieve that it's achievable I will tell
you a great success story is one of the
strong first instructors and he is truly
a product to the system the gentleman's
name is Steve freebies and is a music
professor he was severely injured his
lower back was herniated very bad he
spent eight or nine months in bed and
percocet was very bad and then he
decided to become a man decided to Train
seriously for strength for flexibility
training like a real athlete after
getting the proper medical clearance and
so on of course so fast forward to today
Steve freidy's who is 59 if I'm not
mistaken he holds a number of American
Records for his age group in the
deadlift and he deadlifts without a belt
NST freidy's 59 year old man who used to
have horrendously messed up back can do
suspended sized planes just like when
down so you big sis is out there thing
that you're too old or too whatever
alone you just got it you just got a
shape up special all right such touching
on the all right
I will load it up I'll raise my hand I'm
one of those sissies if and I've had
this I think there are many to dues that
are there's the nut there the nice to
have things then the must-have things
and for me it's been at least a decade
maybe 20 years where I've had these
suspended side splits on the to-do list
and it just gets it gets
renewed you know it's kind of like car
insurance like I renew it every year but
I never really make any use of it so uh
we'll deal with that we'll get you there
you know it's whether it's a worthwhile
goal or not to pursue yeah obviously
there's the obvious just because it is
there and there's no way of judge that
kind of go
somebody climbs to the mountain somebody
somebody learns to do a site split is
that something that you need to do for
your performance outside of several
sports like Taekwondo or gymnastics no
you really don't
is that going to improve your well-being
I do have to say that the sense of
freedom that you have in your hips when
you can system they can do a whole split
it's really pretty awesome to have that
feeling of freedom in the hips you can
only know that freedom if you also have
known what not to have it if that makes
any sense
right of course so I will periodically
know for a while I kind of an odd trick
to get too serious they take some time
you know stretch very lightly kind of
stay might keep maybe at 70% and I'll
just make the push again and bring it
back and I always really enjoy that
feeling of freedom so that's it's a
decision but let's talk about this
mobility or flexibility business let's
talk about how people should proceed
about it so mobility pretty much we're
talking about the full range of motion
in the joint when the length of the
muscle is not an issue so let's use an
example of a full squat okay so if
you're in a full squat you know not a
whole lot of muscles are preventing you
from hitting that range of motion so
there may be a possible that you need to
just pretty much get your joint moving
smoother so what does that mean folks it
just literally means just doing a whole
bunch of squats very slowly and not very
slowly just slowly and building up
progressively range of motion I'm also a
conditioned on most of the famous Soviet
scientists who was a kind of health guru
he would perform this movements every
day he'll perform 100 squats every day
and hundred other other things if you're
not up for doing that you just simply
hold down to the doorway so you just
unload yourself partially you
your weight more to the heels to make it
easier in your knees and we start
squatting and don't go to pain you know
be very progressive go as deep as you
can eventually go deeper just do
multiple sets even and the same thing is
true really for pretty much for all the
other joints but obviously they have
joints that's that's a big one and
everybody needs everybody needs this
type of training I like a very simple
joint mobility protocol obvious you can
make this as complex as you want
seriously and many people have but like
in my book kettlebells simple and
sinister that's my latest book I give
this protocol where they're just just a
couple of different exercises you do one
exercise you do is you just kind of a
move the next to some of a weight around
your head in a circle a halo listen up
the shoulders and other exercise you do
is a very particular type of squat kind
of a prying goblet squad that's a
terrific exercise so you can do search
online prying goblet squad and just for
people I remember the first time I heard
you say that embarrassed myself at the
certification because I thought you were
saying goblin squat and I asked you what
a goblin squat is so for pay it is a
goblet like drinking out of a goblet
goblet squad the name right and John and
it's a terrific type of a squat
that's literally squad for the people
see the problem with the squat exercise
is most people are don't know how to
move well they're tight and you try to
put the bar in their back and they just
cannot do that so the goblet squat is
kind of a squad for the people that then
developed and the prying that is added
to that is something that really allows
you to increase your mobility and
flexibility so what you need to do when
you're trying to get get your
flexibility increase let's say that's a
mobility let's pick any exercise that
you're doing any kind of stretch that
you're doing whatever it is so there are
certain rules that you need to abide by
and I call these the 3s so stress your
strength find space and spread the load
use strength
find space spread the load so what does
that so what does that mean exactly -
well let's use an example of the squad
using strength for the squad means
pulling yourself down into the squat
instead of just dropping yourself using
example of the split instead of a trying
to drop yourself down into the split
you're very actively pushing your feet
out like you're trying to spread the
walls apart so spreading the walls apart
that means you're using strength find
space so what does finding space me
finding space mean just pretty much kind
of a prying and moving your body into
the position and trying to find more
space in the joint and also try to
loosen up the fascia that sheet that
fiber sheet around your muscles it's a
very good analogy would be trying to
pull a post out of the ground so let's
say you're trying to pull a post out of
the ground it's a concrete post you pull
out hard and it's not going to come out
and I can tell you because I have tried
then I just what are you doing down in
Southern California I know that was not
a girl vandalizing parking lot work
oh and back in the past we had a house
and we bought a house and there was some
some things in the bag that I wanted to
demolish so I'm trying to pull all this
concrete posts so I tie a nylon rope to
this post attach it to a crowbar get a
nice strong sumo deadlift position I
pull well what happens is the nylon rope
rips and I do a backflip into the pilot
dirt because I'm very smart I do this
two more times and then my wife Julie
walks by says you know you could just
kind of wiggle it around pride I said oh
that's right honey
so the same thing is really with your
flexibility
so let's Tim let's use the and let's use
the example of the straddle let's say
you're trying to get to straddle instead
of simply trying to force yourself down
so push the straddle meaning side splits
a side split but maybe lying on your
stomach or maybe sitting out doesn't
really matter either way so you look
like a frog on its stomach pretty much
so what you're trying to do is what
you're trying to do is not just force
your way in one direction but you're
trying to kind of a pry and loosen up in
every direction possible so let's say
that you are
let's say you are resting on your form
so you're trying to get it to this this
straddle
so your first pushing your legs out but
then you're also kind of tilting your
pelvis back and forth then you're going
to try to kind of wiggle your butt
side-to-side then you will try to turn
your body one way you're going to try to
turn your body the other way so pretty
much what you're doing is you're taking
advantage of the fact that you're faucet
that covers your muscles it runs in all
sorts of different directions
kinda like plywood so you need to loosen
it up in a lot of different ways so if
you keep going in different directions
all around you will progress those goals
so much faster so you use strength find
space and spread the load and again
spreading the load just pretty much
means that you are not just trying to
focus on that particular joint so you're
just spreading it all around and
relaxation is the absolutely absolutely
sation and patience are the two things
that are absolutely fundamental if
you're trying to get a high level of
flexibility like a split you see you get
a recommendation let's say all hold this
stretch for and they'll give you some
duration 30 seconds or whatever like how
did they arrive at that number I have no
idea just somebody decided well that
sounds like a nice round number
let's recommend that but what you're
trying to do it's disturbing how much of
the world comes about that way well it's
like how many glasses of water you're
supposed to drink it it's just the same
thing and so you have hold the stretch
for 30 seconds but the fact is you're
trying to wear out your stretch reflex
you're trying to lick the muscle relax
and depending on your fiber composition
depending on your mental state emotional
state training history injury history
that can take different time so just
don't worry about it so you just get in
this position you kind of a pry a little
bit for a while and then you just relax
and when you relax you try to breathe
through that tight spot when I say
breathe through I'm saying just listen
to my breathing you completely release
the tension totally if you do this which
is pretty much what most people do when
they're trying to stretch you're
tightening up the muscles you just have
to completely let go you have to be
patient
and you have to spend you have to spend
good half an hour 40 minutes in this
type of practice that day if you really
are serious about reaching that level
how long I'm sorry about 30 or 40
minutes but even if you don't well if
there are ways of doing it faster Tim
but that involves isometric stretching
and that's a little bit more technically
involved to talk about here and the show
but even if you do not pursue this
extreme flexibility goal even if you
just want to be flexible to whatever
level you want to be flexible in
understand that the idea of relaxation
breathing and patience are absolutely
fundamental you have to be patient
flexibility training is not something
you should ever do when you're in a
hurry for some appointment it's
something you should save for the end of
the day let's say you're watching some
TV show just and going stretch or you're
reading a book one of my colleagues dr.
mark Chang a strong first senior
instructor he has these beautiful side
splits the way he worked up to his side
split is she would just sit and read a
book hit a straddle on the ground and
then at some point whenever he felt like
he could he just tried to spread his
legs wider and that's it you go back to
reading his book so you see acquiring
the flexibility it's an exercise in
patience so if you do not have the
patience or if you do not have the time
I suggest to just give up and the the
isometric just to touch on that is is
that a a variant or press the same thing
as PMF the pretty much like sequential
sort of contractions and and and release
so here's how this works in a nutshell
imagine that you are let's say that
you're stretched out far and it feels
like I cannot go any farther the muscle
cannot get any tighter then you slowly
contract that muscle slowly it's
important for safety and you build up
the tension and you hold that tension
for awhile and then you release that
tension the important thing is again
release and when you have released
you'll see this contrast so in a way you
kind of a climb from the fire into the
frying pan is still hot but not as hot
and you can eke out just a little bit
more range of motion so
these isometric contractions can be
added to any type of stretching and the
idea the very important thing about them
is you need to make them steady do not
make them jerky in any way
the only thing about them that sudden is
that release other way steady steady
steady and when you're when you're
holding the contraction and this is hard
to quantify but the as a guideline what
percentage of maximal contraction is
that you know there are various there
are various methods some of them attempt
for you to bring the attention to a very
very high level gradually still very
gradually but 32i level to the point
where the muscle literally shuts down
something KO Golgi tendon organ just
fires book so just goes that's an
advanced technique it takes takes a lot
of practice you can go or you can just
go for a very steady tension of about
thirty percent and just try to stay
there for pretty much as long as you can
handle it just the important thing is
that the tension doesn't diminish you
know whatever when you feel like the
tension is about to diminish whatever
level that you've chosen then you just
release and then you pry a little
farther private as well mark Chang has
one of the most impressive Turkish get
ups I've ever seen very impressive
people who are not familiar with that
move you could certainly do a search and
see some examples that is a very very
very technical move at the Turkish get
up the beautiful thing about the Turkish
get up that's someone like yourself who
is a minimalist would appreciate is you
get done so much for so little it's it's
one of those amazing all-around wants
Topshop exercises and some food for
thought for people in general when you
think about training earlier we talked
about various trade offs what to do in
the program is training is just like a
budget budget for a person who has a
regular paycheck so you have to decide
am I going to buy a couch or I'm going
to go on vacation am I going to get in
debt and do bowls I'm going to buy
really good couch and not go on vacation
or buy cheap couch and take a short
vacation you want point so there are a
lot of choices a lot of trade-offs and
these trade-offs have to do with both
your time but also with a gap
the endocrine system your endocrine
system can only handle so much training
right and all these different types of
training that they they are added up and
plus heels of the stresses of your life
and so on so whenever you're deciding
and what it is that you do for your
exercise you have to identify really
what's important stripped and under
seneschal and make compromises and
sacrifices somewhere now true for so
many areas I wanted to come back to
something you said about oversharing
earlier and the because it was the the
the flaws or the the dangers of
oversharing in malfunction the
malfunction even better of oversharing
so that's that's kind of my my business
model i guess but the the i'd love
teaching as my opinion I'm not judging
oh no no no no you could feel free to
judge I think I think that oversharing
is a problem although but I'd love to
hear your thoughts on what Americans
could learn from perhaps the culture you
grew up in in the former Soviet Union or
vice versa because I personally and this
is not meant as a slight at all I've so
much respect for so many people in the
former Soviet Union
most of my observation has been in the
in the sports arena a sports arena I
mean looking at people like Konstantin
Konstantinov or dmitriy klokov or just
these these amazing specimens but I have
a very tough time when I meet some
people from the former Soviet Union
socially with getting through the
cultural differences and I'm usually I
don't usually find that hard unless
there's a lot of vodka involved um but
well that's that's the social lubricant
it you just need to you just need to
drink more vodka that did scare so what
what could what could Americans learn
from from the culture you grew up in or
vice versa okay well first of all I'm
speaking about the Soviet culture I'm
not talking about the current culture
the post-soviet culture because
unfortunate this is my observation that
often times when different countries
learn something from America
they choose to learn other things that
worth learning right like I really would
like to see for Russia to learn about
free enterprise about fair competition
about freedom and unfortunately the
things they're learning or not these are
like reality to that's what they're
learning and that's that's not unique to
Russia that's that's pretty universal
around the world for some reason instead
of getting the best from America people
are just sort of getting the Las Vegas
version America so and what people can
learn what Americans can learn is they
can learn to limit their choices you
mentioned earlier the paradox of choice
they is it Barry Schwartz book right
that's right it's a very good book I
enjoyed the book very much and I think
that is I think that is very true when
there are so many choices to exercise
these choices are difficult it takes a
lot of processing power there's a great
moment in film Moscow on the Hudson
Knoll film with Robin Williams where he
walks into an American grocery store he
sees coffee everywhere he says coffee
coffee coffee he just passes up so what
is very difficult in this country is
exercising the choice because options
are just so many and choices are
difficult and in fact you will find out
that a number of Eastern Europeans who
have failed to assimilate or fail to
make the life in America are the ones
who just have a hard time making choices
they're useful for a lot of choices
being made for them and there is obvious
downside to that in terms of freedom
there is obviously an upside of it
because there's there are fewer
distractions so you personally not you
Tim but the listeners you need to figure
out how to limit your choices then make
these choices and stick to them the
Konstantinov and the clock event these
other Russian athletes you mentioned
these guys do not train with 360 degree
but squeezing scott curl bench that you
see in a typical gym
these guys have the basics and they just
hammer just absolutely hammer in the
basics and the I'm a big admirer of the
free enterprise system unfortunately as
much as that's worked in so many fields
and industries is completely failed in
the exercise industry and fitness
industry because it's constantly chasing
its tell tale with the novelty the new
the best or whatever and it's a fad that
just goes away again but a simple fact
is certain things do not change what I
think also I think Americans could
really learn is they could learn from
themselves they could learn from the
past I have a great idea lized image of
America that I did when I was growing up
and that came from my favorite film is
the Magnificent Seven it's interesting
that they showed that film when my dad
was in the service and was came out
first and I saw it many years later they
showed it again and I was just very
impressed with this ëthis that you can
see they're these very strong
self-reliant people who don't waste
words who do not get stuck in a part of
hierarchy push that are right into the
sunset I think is very powerful
I think if America were just a little
bit more reconnect with what makes it
makes it great it wouldn't have to
search elsewhere we can talk about
American exceptionalism there is such a
thing as American exceptionalism because
no other country has that same sense of
freedom has the same opportunities and
that same spirit of everything is
possible no other place so even people
who go out and start criticizing America
that's usually it happens because of
envy that's really all it is so maybe
let's just go back to the older times
maybe some of them didn't even exist Old
West whatever it is we're just people
had the pride in being pioneers the
pride in just getting ahead
or unless even looks Tim let's have a
look in the 50s or 60s like today where
do the brightest young people what did
they end up doing they end up designing
apps right well in the 50s and 60s they
design spaceships right so the dreams
were just so much bigger and right now
here's this hot new app golly gee Martha
so let's just try to go back to what
made this country great to a grand
vision and not just little petty little
cap stuff who are some of the the people
for you whether current day or hundreds
of years ago or more who exemplify the
best of what America has to offer if
people listening we're looking for role
map role models to revisit or to try to
emulate who would you put on that list
also the founding fathers Ben Franklin
definitely there are so many great
people in American history that worth
emulating there's the great generation
of the world war two these really quiet
people we just went and got the job done
and then try and complain about the lack
of opportunities of life is hard and
we're having it so tough there many I
have a and just you know even people who
are just even people who are younger I
have a good friend Lee Stoney Stoney was
a Marine he found a Vietnam and Gaston
is just such a great person who is such
a positive outlook on life
he just is a true American you will not
hear him complain he thinks that America
is about great things and that's what
seriously this is what disappoints me as
an as a naturalized American because I
think America is so much bigger so much
better than its than it has been so just
look back into it was before no I I'm of
course born and raised here but very
much feel the same way and it's been
uplifting to me though to see that
although the
the the kids building apps as some of
which are very world-changing I think
but many of which are not and are very
trivial if we look at apps is just the
new software applications and mobile
devices that is the new computers
they're people changing the world but
there there's also been a resurgence of
of people aspiring to be like Elon Musk
for instance who is building spaceships
sure and that that's been really
reassuring to me in some ways but the
Ben Franklin example I think is a great
one and for anyone who hasn't read the
the Walter Isaacson biography of
Benjamin Franklin it's a fascinating
fascinating picture of a deep very
capable but also hilarious figure I
wanted to just in enclosing a few more
questions but the first is how do you
personally limit your choices to avoid
the coffee coffee coffee experience and
the data and the distraction how do you
what are some ways in which you up you
contain those choices in life tim
professionally I use this I use the same
technique that you use for voting
I remember that you mentioned that you
don't like following the current current
affairs before you vote you just talked
to a number of people whose opinion you
respect and who vote the way who believe
the way you do so I do the same thing in
training pretty much so when I do when I
do research most of my time is spent
reading the classic Soviet texts and
studies and once in a while
I rise up on periscope and I'll talk to
several people I respect in the industry
and ask what's going on what's new and
they will just brief me on that most of
the time frankly nothing's going but so
this is an example of this is an example
of my technique I am very ruthless about
limiting my communications I am very
protective of my time too right
overprotective my time to read
and that's what it no that's I think
this is a really important topic and I
appreciate the answers and I also
encourage everyone to think about how
they can create their own choice
minimal lifestyle so they can preserve
their creativity and unique abilities
for the store I think also you need to
we need to we need to teach people
around us need to understand that not to
over communicate it's again it's an
interesting modern phenomenon that it's
play by play everything happens to be
played by play it's like you know kids
in the car
are there yet are we there yet no we're
driving we're on route and no so uh this
has been really fun
bobble I really appreciate the time I
figured - how much what what are you up
to focused on currently where can people
learn more about you where would you
suggest people look - to learn more
about the things you work on thank you
Jim my company's called strong first
strong first calm is the website and we
are about changing lives making the
world a stronger place strewed through
strength so we teach various skills
through courses certifications and so on
so just we stopped by at strong first
comm and I also recommend you pick up a
copy of my book kettlebells simple and
sinister and I can assure you that this
book definitely fits with the spirit of
this conversation there's absolutely
nothing fluff no fluff there whatsoever
and just just to to to also add my my
own two cents related to my direct
experience problems methods your methods
poeple and those that you've distilled
from all the the minds and practitioners
the operators that you've researched and
observed a really do work so for those
people who know me I obviously conduct
hundreds and thousands of various
experiments in my house right now just
looks like a laboratory / pharmacy
there's so much crap strewn about
related to all the various odd
a human guinea pig stuff that I'm doing
and I've really run the gamut and and
tested so many things available out
there and in a world that tends to
complicate to profit I think you really
simplify to results and so I commend you
for that and I've seen tremendous
tremendous transformations in my own
life thanks to a lot of your advice so I
really encourage people to check it out
and this was this was a blast
so hopefully sometimes you can do it
around to in person but thank you so
much the time pawel and until next time
thank you Jim man flower - all right
same to you this episode of the Tim
Farriss show is brought to you by
99designs 99designs
is the world's largest online
marketplace of graphic designers and I
have used 99 designs for years including
to get cover concepts for the 4-hour
body which went on to become number one
New York Times number-one Wall Street
Journal it was a huge hit and here's how
it works and you can check everything
out including some of my competitions
you can see these book covers and so on
at 99designs com forward slash Tim
whether you need a logo a car wrap a web
design and app a thumbnail a t-shirt
whatever you go to 99 designs com you
describe your project and then within a
week or less you have tons of designers
around the world who compete for your
business and submit different ideas and
designs and drafts you have an original
design that you love or you pay nothing
it is fantastic
I have used it I have mentioned it
before including in the 4-hour workweek
as a resource check it out 99designs com
forward slash Tim and if you use that
link you'll be able to see what I've
done on the platform you will also get
$99 as an upgrade for free which will
get you more designs more submissions so
check it out and until next time thank
you for listening